en italia de cara a las festividades
navideñas el primer ministro anunció un
confinamiento parcial del 21 de
diciembre al 6 de mayo desde el 21 de
diciembre hasta el 6 de enero estará
prohibido viajar entre regiones para
evitar el aumento de contagios todo el
territorio será declarado zona roja
antes y durante los días festivos de
jordi esteve y presstv
mientras en austria suavizarán las
restricciones durante navidad pero el
país entrará en su tercer confinamiento
desde el 26 de diciembre acompañado por
un programa masivo de pruebas
es claramente mejor visitar un lugar con
un test en lugar de cerrarlo todo y
aquellos que no quieren hacerlo no lo
hagan nadie está obligando a ir de
vacaciones oa un concierto
de cultura fans del otún gay ton siguen
contratando
con alrededor de 8 mil decesos el
porcentaje de muertos por habitante en
suecia es mucho mayor que en los países
vecinos ahora las autoridades
recomiendan usar el tapabocas en el
transporte público
el máximo de personas en reuniones en
restaurantes se reducirá a 4 la venta de
alcohol será prohibida después de las 8
pm en bares y restaurantes esto será a
partir del 24 de diciembre
el anuncio de las restricciones llega
después de que el rey carlos 16 criticar
a la respuesta sueca contra el virus
diciendo que el país había fallado